Nintendo's weird business decisions are
getting even weirder as they push sell
the back to 2017 and make it the only
playable game at this year's e3 god I
hope it's good I'm Kate and this is yet
another news story about delayed games
after revealing a worldwide release date
for its NX gaming console Nintendo has
announced the delay of its upcoming
Legend of Zelda game now share chilled
to release both on Wii U & NX in 2017
the company confirmed that the game will
be its only playable title at e3 this
year in order to provide attendees a
complete immersion The Legend of Zelda
which is a working title was originally
scheduled to launch for Wii U in 2015
the title was initially delayed to give
the development team more time to
realize several new possibilities for
the game a 2016 release window was
confirmed in November 2015 after
Nintendo had listed it as TBD for a
period of time the information confirms
reports which surfaced earlier this year
that the game would be launching
simultaneously across the NX and wii u
although the allegations cited a 2016
release Nintendo has not shown much of
the game yet besides a few short
trailers and one screenshots is your
excitement waning now that Nintendo keep
letting us down
how many more weird and bad decisions
could they make let me know in the
comments all come and find me on Twitter
I'm at how not to draw thanks for
watching and for all your gaming and
entertainment news keep it GameSpot